TO START THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
WE'RE GONNA WAIT TILL WE HAVE
QUORUM AND SO IN THE INTERIM
WILL START AS A SUB COMMITTEE --
WE'RE GONNA START FIRST WITH
MISTER RAMOS.
WHO IS PRESENTING AB THREE TWO
THREE ABOUT THE MISTER DAILY
WITH MR GRAYSON?
RESTAURANTS IF YOU WANNA.
COME FORWARD THANK YOU.
IS THIS ON THERE I'M SORRY I
FORGOT TO HIT THE RED BUTTON BOB
SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS I
WILL BE PRESENTING ON AB THREE
TWO THREE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAILY.
AS WE ALL KNOW TOO WELL
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE STATES
THAT IS MOST PRONE TO NATURAL
DISASTERS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
CALIFORNIA HAS RECEIVED ROUGHLY
SIX POINT THREE MILLION BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL GRANTS.
AND THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
MOST RECENT FIRES WHICH WILL
LIKELY EXCEED THREE BILLION
DOLLARS.
BY ESTABLISHING A DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS ACCOUNT AB THREE
TWO THREE WILL ENSURE THAT EVEN
DURING AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN OUR
STATE WILL HAVE THE NECESSARY
CASH RESERVES TO PAY FOR
IMMEDIATE RESPONSES AND RECOVERY.
BECAUSE THE TIMING AND AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS IS OFTEN
UNCERTAIN.
IT IS ESPECIALLY CRITICAL THAT
WE HAVE THE NECESSARY RESERVES
ON HAND.
AS WE KNOW IN THE IMMEDIATE
AFTERMATH OF THE NATURAL
DISASTERS QUICK RESPONSE IS
CRITICAL TO PROVIDING BASIC
NEEDS AND ESTABLISHING THE
GROUNDWORK FOR EVENTUAL RECOVERY.
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAILY I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
ARRIVAL.
START ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN FAVOR.
ANY WITNESSES APPROACHED.
QUESTIONS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE I'M SORRY I SHOULD
COME QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE FIRST -- FINANCE
DEVOTE.
GREG BREASTS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ADMINISTRATION HAS NO
FORMAL PROPOSED.
NO FORMAL POSITION ON THIS BILL
WE'RE STILL EVALUATING THE
POTENTIAL EFFECTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
WE WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT --
WE'D LIKE TO RETAIN AS MUCH
FINANCIAL FLEXIBILITY AS
POSSIBLE.
I WANTED DRESSING NEEDS FOR THE
STATE CREATING A SEPARATE
RESERVE FOR A SPECIFIC PURPOSE
LIKELY REDUCES THAT FLEXIBILITY --
BUT WE ARE HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON THIS
ISSUE AS PART OF THE ONGOING
BUDGET DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WHAT.
YEAH I GUESS -- MY QUESTION IS
THIS IS THIS AND AND MAYBE WE
CAN.
WHAT YOU SAID WHAT PART OF
FINANCES SAID THERE I WASN'T
AWARE THAT THIS THIS IS A
RESERVE ACCOUNT -- SO WHERE IS
THE FRONT WEARS A FUNDING
EXPECTED TO COME FROM FROM.
EXIST REVENUE I MEAN WHERE WHERE
WE WERE HAPPY IT SAYS THERE'S NO
THERE THE BILL WILL HAVE NO COST
BUT WE HAVE.
SO WE CREATE A FUND WHERE DOES
THE MONEY COME FROM SO.
THE SERVER WOULD THEM THE TIMING
AND AMOUNT OF FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS AS PART OF THE
REASON FOR THE RESERVE THIS
THERE SO THAT WE HAVE AMPLE TIME
TO GET THAT REIMBURSEMENT BACK
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THEY WOULD THEN GO INTO THIS
THIS A RESERVE.
HEAR ME IT LOOKS LIKE THERE
WOULD HAVE NEED TO BE SOME SEED
MONEY PUT INTO THE ACCOUNT
EITHER FROM THE GENERAL FUND OR
FROM SOME OTHER FUNDING SOURCES
TO GET IT.
YOU KNOW -- FILLED UP TO TWO IS
A STARTING POINT.
SO IS ANYBODY GIVEN A THOUGHT TO
WHAT THAT NUMBER MIGHT BE.
FINANCES NOT -- DETERMINE ANY
SPECIFIC A THRESHOLD DOLLAR
AMOUNT.
DESCRIPTION I WILL I WILL TRY MY
BEST.
I'VE ALWAYS REYES LARYNGITIS
YEAH.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM -- BUT AS
WE WE ALREADY REIMBURSE AND WE
ALREADY ADDRESS EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS WELL BUT IT'S OUT OF
THE IF I UNDERSTAND IT QUICKLY.
THE MAIN RESERVE ACCOUNTS.
AND WHAT THIS WOULD SIMPLY DO IS
CREATE A A WAY THAT WE CAN
BETTER TRACK.
FEMALE -- PAYMENTS THE TIMING OF
IT AND THEN ALSO BEGAN TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT SHOULD BE PUT
AWAY. FOR EMERGENCIES IN THE
FUTURE.
BASED ON HEALTH REIMBURSEMENTS
COME IN AND HOW THEY'RE
DISPERSED.
SO IT'S REALLY SERVING MORE TO
ADD GREATER FLEXIBILITY AND
TRACKING -- DATA AS FAR AS WE
SEATS AND DISBURSEMENTS.
THANK YOU -- MISTER WILL.
TAKE IT WAS CHAIRMAN OF THE THE
ALSO FOR YOU AND STATE LAW SAYS
THAT WHEN THE BALANCE OF THE SFU
GETS ABOVE A CERTAIN POINT.
THAT TRIGGERS AN AUTOMATIC ONE
QUARTER PERCENTAGE POINT
REDUCTION IN THE STATEWIDE SALES
TAX SO EVERY TIME SOMEONE
PROPOSES CREATING A NEW RESERVE
ACCOUNT WHAT I THINK IN MY MIND
IS THAT DELAYS THE DATE WHEN
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA A
REDUCTION ON THEIR SALES TAX AND
THIS IS A NEW YEAR WHEN WE HAVE
A TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
SURPLUS I THINK THAT WE ARE WE
SHOULD HAVE LET THE SFU EXCEED
THAT AMOUNT.
BOB HOWEVER IN THIS CASE I'M
GONNA GO AGAINST THAT.
WHAT WHAT I DO REGULARLY AND
VOTE FOR IT BECAUSE I ACTUALLY
THINK THAT YOU BRING SOME
EXCELLENT POINTS UP WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE STATE'S NEED --
FOR DISASTER PREPAREDNESS THESE
ARE TRULY -- AYE AYE --
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR WHICH WE NEED
TO HAVE A SEPARATE RESERVE
ACCOUNT ACCOUNT SET ASIDE AND
THE THINGS THAT WE REALLY CAN'T
FORESEE WHEN THE NEED MIGHT
OCCUR THAT WE NEED TO TAP INTO
THAT SO.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BUT I I'D LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE US TO TO THINK
CAREFULLY ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH THE SEPARATE RESERVE
ACCOUNTS BECAUSE I REALLY THINK
THAT.
THE PEOPLE OF CAL CALIFORNIA
DESERVE THAT ONE QUARTER PERCENT
REDUCTION IN THEIR SALES TAX
RATE.
THANK YOU IT JUST ADDITIONAL
CLARIFYING DOCTOR WHICH QUESTION
SO.
THIS ACCOUNT PART THE REASON FOR
THIS ACCOUNT IS.
BECAUSE IN RECENT YEARS THERE'S
BEEN NUMEROUS EXPENDITURES ALL
COME FROM DIFFERENT PLACES.
THIS WOULD REALLY ALLOW US TO
HAVE A MUCH CLEARER COUNTING ON
WHAT'S BEING SPENT.
ON SPECIFIC DISASTERS WHAT IS
ALSO OCCURRING IN WHERE THAT
MONEY IS COMING FROM BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW IT'S SORT OF A A
MISHMASH OF PLACES DEPENDING ON
THOSE DEPARTMENTS.
IT WAS DESIGNED THAT WAY BECAUSE
FRANKLY THESE DISASTERS WERE ONE
OFFS AND THEY WERE INFREQUENT
NOW THAT THEY'VE BECOME
UNFORTUNATELY ALMOST AN ANNUAL
OCCURRENCE.
WE WE FIND THE NEED.
TO TAKE A MUCH CLOSER LOOK HAVE
A MUCH MORE SET GUIDELINE OF
PRINCIPLES AND AND PERHAPS A
SEPARATE COUNTY SO WE'RE REALLY
UNDERSTAND IT MAKE SURE THE
MONEY IS ACTUALLY.
GETTING TO WHERE IT'S SUPPOSED
TO BECAUSE WE ARE APPROPRIATING
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT TO DO WITH
THESE DISASTERS WHICH I THINK IS
COMPLETELY APPROPRIATE WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT IT'S EASY TO TRACK THAT
MONEY AS WELL.
ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
I'LL GO BACK -- ANY.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT OPPOSED.
MR ALMOST DID YOU WANNA CLOSE
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU -- WE ARE STILL
WAITING FOR FOR SO WE'LL BE
TAKING THAT PROPOSAL UP WE HAVE
COR THANK YOU.
MR OBERNOLTE HAS TO PROPOSALS IN
FROM THE COMMITTEE AS WELL.
MR WILL NOTICE PRESENTING ECA
ELEVEN AS WELL AS AB.
EIGHT FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WITH YOUR PERMISSION
WILL START WITH A CA.
ELEVEN I'M SURE WE'LL ALL AWARE
OF THIS COMMITTEE OF THE GREAT
WORK THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S DOES IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S MISSION.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN INTEGRAL PART
OF OUR BUDGETING PROCESS AND OR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SINCE THEY
WERE FORMED IN NINETEEN FORTY
NINE OF COURSE THEIR FORM. TO BE
A COUNTERPOINT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY PROPOSITION ONE
FORTY PASSED WHICH PASSED STRICT
REGULATION AND CAPS ON
LEGISLATIVE SPENDING
UNFORTUNATELY THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IS INCLUDED
UNDERNEATH THE PROP ONE FORTY
CAPS.
PRIOR TO NINETEEN NINETY THE LA --
DID ANALYSIS NOT JUST OF THE
BUDGET BUT OF EVERY SINGLE BILL
THAT WENT BEFORE THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THAT
ANALYSIS WAS ARE NOT ONLY TIMELY
BUT ALSO VERY HELPFUL IN EATING
THE LEGISLATURE.
IN NAVIGATING THE THE MAZE OF
ALL THOSE BILLS AGO BEFORE
APPROPRIATIONS AFTER PROP ONE
FORTY PASSED THE STAFF OF THE LA --
WAS CUT BY OVER 60% AND IT IS
NEVER BEEN RESTORED TO GIVE YOU
AN IDEA OF THE LA -- CURRENTLY
HAS ABOUT AS MUCH STAFF AS THEY
HAD IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX AND
THE STATE BUDGET AND THE
ACCOMPANYING PROGRAMS HAVE
INCREASED OVER 5000% SINCE THEM.
SO THIS CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
ACA ELEVEN WOULD REMOVE THE LA --
FROM UNDERNEATH THE PROP ONE
FORTY CAPS A ON THE ALLOW US TO
BE TO RESTORE THE LA -- TO
CLOSER TO WHAT THEIR ORIGINAL
MISSION WAS.
NORMALLY I'M A SMALL GOVERNMENT
PERSON NORMALLY I'M NOT IN FAVOR
OF EXPANDING ANY DEPARTMENT OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT IN
THIS CASE I MAKE AN EXCEPTION
BECAUSE THE ONLY I WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE THE FISCAL WATCHDOG. FOR
NOT ONLY STATE SPENDING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THAT DEPARTMENT I
WANT TO HAVE AS MANY STAFF AS
THEY NEED TO DO THEIR JOB SO.
I I THINK THIS IS A GREAT THING
FOR NOT ONLY OUR FISCAL
CONSERVANCY BUT ALSO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA DOWN AT THE PROPER
TIME WOULD REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
ON A SCALE OF GET THE PART OF
FINANCE.
KRISTIN SHELTON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON THIS AND PROPOSAL AT THIS
TIME.
HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES THAT COULD
EXIST IF THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
IS CARVED OUT.
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S SPENDING
AND THEN THERE WOULD BE COST FOR
THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO PUT
THIS MEASURE ON THE BALLOT.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE GO TO THE
COMMITTEE CAN WE TAKE ROLE TO
ESTABLISH MORE.
KING HERE OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
PRO. TO COOPER YEAH FONG.
FRAZIER [inaudible]
GARCIA.
JONES SAWYER LACKEY LIMóN.
MATHIS [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
MOST.
REYES REVERSE [inaudible]
STONE.
WEBER HERE WICKS HERE'S WHAT
YOU'RE CALM EXPRESS THANK YOU
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN -- SO MISTER OBERNOLTE
YOU AND I HAVE THIS --
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS BILL A
MONTH OR SO AGO AND I STILL HAVE
THE SAME CONCERNS YOU YOU SEEK
TO REMOVE.
THE SPENDING CAP FOR THE LA YEAH
THAT'S WHAT THIS WOULD DO RIGHT.
NOT QUITE WHAT I PROPOSE YOU TO
DO IS TO MOVE THE LA -- OUT FROM
THE EXISTING PROP ONE FORTY
SPENDING CAP FOR THE LEGISLATURE
SO THAT THAT CAP WOULD STILL
EXIST FOR THE LEGISLATURE BUT
THE LA -- WOULD EXIST
INDEPENDENTLY OF THAT CAP AND
THEY DON'T GET BUDGET EVERY YEAR
AS EVERY OTHER DEPARTMENT THIS
THERE'S NO CAP PLACED ON HOW
MUCH THEY COULD RECEIVE IS NOT
SPECIFICALLY IN THE LA ALBEIT AN
ITEM FOR NEGOTIATION EACH YEAR
WHEN WE SAT THERE BUDGET.
AND SO -- PROP ONE FIFTY EIGHT
WHICH WAS PRESENTED TO THE
VOTERS IN -- NINETEEN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO YEAH -- WAS REJECTED
BY THE VOTERS THEY DIDN'T WANT
TO DO THE VERY THING THAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING THAT WE SHOULD DO
TODAY BECAUSE I DIDN'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE.
WITH -- ALLOWING THEM TO BE
SEPARATED AND ALSO NOT TO HAVE
ANY SORT OF CONSTITUTIONAL CAP
SO I'M JUST WONDERING -- I GUESS.
YOU ARE UNDER THE IMPRESSION
THAT THE VOTERS WOULD FEEL
DIFFERENTLY THIS TIME I AM AT
AGE IS ACTUALLY QUESTION BECAUSE
AS YOU SAY PROP ONE FIFTY EIGHT
WAS REJECTED BY THE VOTERS
NINETEEN NINETY TWO BUT I THINK
THAT THE LA -- GOT CAUGHT UP IN
THE BACKLASH OF VOTER OPINION
AGAINST THE LEGISLATURE THE
LEGISLATURE WAS VERY UNPOPULAR
WITH VOTERS AT THAT TIME AND
THAT'S WHY PROP ONE FORTY WAS.
ONE YOU SEEN NOW.
I PLEAD THE FIFTH.
BUT I I DO THINK THAT THE
SETTLEMENT IS IS VERY DIFFERENT
NOW THE POLITICAL CLIMATE VERY
DIFFERENT NOW THAN IT WAS IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO I ALSO THINK
THAT.
WE DIDN'T DO A VERY GOOD JOB OF
ARTICULATING THE CASE FOR WHY
THE ONLY -- EXISTS AND WHY WE
NEED A STRONG AND INDEPENDENT LA --
TO COUNTERBALANCE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND HOW THE LA --
ACTUALLY HELPS TO SAVE TAXPAYER
MONEY SO -- I WOULD ARGUE THAT A
DOLLAR INVESTED NEARLY DO YOU
YIELDS MANY DOLLARS BACK AND
TAXPAYER SAVINGS -- AND I FEEL
VERY STRONGLY ABOUT THAT.
OKAY AND I APPRECIATE THAT I
GUESS I'M JUST WARNING HOP I
MEAN THE QUESTION WE'RE GOING TO
BE PRESENTING TO VOTERS IS WE
ARE NOT THE QUESTION WHAT THE
REQUEST IS THAT WE WOULD LIKE.
NOT ONLY THE MONEY THAT YOU
CURRENTLY GIVE THE STATE FOR
THAT -- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
BUT NOW WE WANT MORE MONEY FOR
THE LA IS OFFICE TO DO THE EXACT
SAME JOB.
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY CORRECT
HOWEVER THE REASON WHY THE LA
WAS INSTITUTED IS BECAUSE A
PRIOR TO THE THE PRIOR TO THE
INITIATION OF THE PART IN A
FINANCE.
WE REALLY HAD NO PROFESSIONAL
FINANCE STAFF AT ALL IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WAS
STARTED THAT WAS -- IT
MINISTRATION PERSONNEL THAT WAS
BASICALLY HIRED TO PUT TOGETHER
THE ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET AND
THE LEGISLATURE QUICKLY REALIZE
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
PROFESSIONAL.
OPINIONS OF OUR OWN TO BE ABLE
TO COUNTERACT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS PROPOSING TO
DO SO BASICALLY WE COULD BELIEVE
THE DEAL AFTER.
WITH ALL RESPECT YOU KNOW OR NOT
BELIEVE THEM BUT WE REALLY
DIDN'T HAVE ANY FACTS WHAT WERE
EXPERT PERSONNEL TO BACK US UP
AND THAT'S WHY THERE IS AN ALLEY
OKAY BECAUSE THAT THAT TENSION
IS ALWAYS GOING TO EXIST BETWEEN
THE LEGISLATURE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT THAT
TENSION IS A GOOD THING.
AND YOU'VE YOU DN'T FEEL HAT
THE POLICY ANALYST -- EMPLOYED
BY THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN OF
THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS ARE ENOUGH
TO SATISFY.
THE INCREASE THAT ARE MADE BY
MEMBERS WITH RESPECT TO HAVE
SPENDING.
NO I DO NOT AND I THINK WE'RE
ALL AWARE SWITCHED FROM
SPECIALLY OUR SIDE OF THE AISLE
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE TO
CUT A SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER POLICY
CAUCUS STAFF IN RECENT YEARS.
BECAUSE OF BUDGETARY PRESSURES
YOU KNOW WITHIN OUR OWN CAUCUS
AND AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S A
HEALTHY THING I THINK WE NEED TO
HAVE PEOPLE WHOSE WHOSE JOB IN
FULL TIME OCCUPATION IS
ANALYZING THE FISCAL IMPACTS OF
LEGISLATION ON THE TAXPAYERS A
CALIFORNIA.
THANKS FOR THE GREAT QUESTIONS.
IT WAS FRAZIER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
I KNOW IS A POLICY CHAIR THAT I
HAVE BEEN -- UTILIZING THE
ALEJO'S ANALYSIS ON SEVERAL
DIFFERENT FACETS.
AND THE UNBIASED APPROACH THAT
THEY TAKE.
HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL TO ME IN.
ACTUALLY.
NECESSITATING GOING ON TOURS OR
WHATEVER SO I I REALLY WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS AS A AN
OPPORTUNITY -- THAT AUGMENTS MY
STAFF FOR MY COMMITTEE STAFF --
ABILITY TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS SO I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOU BRING WAS WHERE I
REALLY THINK IT'S ESSENTIAL.
THAT WE EXPAND THEIR ABILITIES
ALSO.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
HOW TO SAY I'M I'M PROUD TO BE A
CO AUTHOR OF THIS PROPOSAL WE?
CAME THROUGH THIS PROPOSAL AS MR
ABILITY MYSELF FOR GOING THROUGH
THE LA -- HIRING PROCESS REALLY
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAD BECOME FRANKLY BECAUSE OF
TERM LIMITS THE NUMBER OF THE
REASONS.
THEY COME A FAIRLY WEAK BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT WE ARE WE ARE A
THREE BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
SYSTEM.
I THINK MISS MELENDEZ PRESENT
EXCELLENT POINT ASKING YOU KNOW
WE HAVE -- FISCAL STOP FROM BOTH
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE IS THIS REALLY
NECESSARY.
I THINK THE THE LA -- HAD
SOMETHING THAT REALLY -- OUR DAY
TO DAY.
FISCAL STAFF CAN'T DO WHICH IS
OUR FISCAL STAFF ARE VERY MUCH
ACTING TO VERY SPECIFIC --
BUDGET PROPOSALS AND HEAD DOWN
TO THE NITTY GRITTY OF POSITIONS
SO THEY'RE THEY'RE REALLY IN THE
OPERATIONS OF GOVERNMENT
BUSINESS WHERE I WAS THE LA --
REALLY AS AS MISTER FRAZIER
POINT OUT CAN BE LOOKING AT
ISSUES LOOKING AT LONGER TERM
ISSUES I KNOW ONE ISSUE.
THAT I'D WISH THEY HAD REALLY
BEEN ABLE TO HELP.
MORE ON AND FRANKLY IT'S OUR
FAULT APPOINT NOT ENGAGE IN THE
EARLY NAM WAS REALLY ON THIS
WILDFIRE ISSUE ON THIS DISASTER
ISSUE SOMETHING THAT.
THEY COULD HELP TAKE A MUCH
LONGER VIEW -- WHERE IS OUR
STAFF IS REALLY?
MEANT TO DO WITH THE BUSINESS OF
THE DAY THE DAY TO DAY BUSINESS
SO -- I I REALLY APPRECIATE
MISTRAL MULTI YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD AND HAVE AN OUT BY PARTS
SUPPOSED TO THIS RIPPLES I THINK
IT IS VERY NECESSARY.
GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE SEEN --
I DON'T THINK EVEN MENTIONED
THAT THE STAFFING COMPARISON
BETWEEN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND LA L. M. L. L. HAS ABOUT
FIFTY STAFF I BELIEVE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE HAS IS A FOR A FOUR
HUNDRED STAFF AND MY AND KRISTIN
SHELTON AGAIN WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT STAFF
HOWEVER -- HUGE PERCENTAGE ABOUT
STAFF A LITTLE BIT OVER HALF ARE
NOT ACTUALLY DOING IT THE BUDGET
AND FISCAL OVERSIGHT WE HAVE OUR
AUDIT AND EVALUATION ARM.
AND WE ALSO HAVE OUR SUPPORT OF
WORK THAT WE DO FROM AN
ACCOUNTING PERSPECTIVE FOR THE
STATE THANK YOU THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT POINT.
EVEN IF YOU JUST NOW 220-020-0
VERSES THE THE FIFTY AND AGAIN --
YEAH WE THINK I THINK THIS
PUZZLE'S LONG OVERDUE WOULD VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE OUR VICE CHAIR
FOR BRING IT FORWARD.
I WAS GOING TO OFF ASK IF
THERE'S ANY TESTIMONY IN FAVOR
OF THIS PROPOSAL.
THE PUBLIC COMMENT IN FAVOR.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT AGAINST.
CANNOT SEE ANY WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MA'AM SECRETARY
COULD YOU CALL THE ROLL TRACY.
ELEVEN KING HI TING AYE
OBERNOLTE FIVE REALTY I BLOOM.
BLOOM HI BRO.
BRO HI CHIU COOPER.
COOPER HI FONG.
FONG AYE FRAZIER.
FEATURE I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA
AYE JONES SAWYER LACKEY HI
LACKEY AYE LIMóN MATHIS.
MATHIS FIVE PARTY MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ.
MULLIN DOES NOT VOTING.
MULLIN MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE NAZARIAN
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON. FOR
ALMOST.
RAMOS FIVE RADIUS REVERSE.
REVERSE AYE RUBIO.
STONE STONE AYE WEBER.
WEBER I WICKS.
WICKS FIVE WHAT.
WOOD HI NICE TWENTY NO ZERO ONE
NOBODY THANK YOU THE STRUGGLE TO
A. B. FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I KNOW
EVERYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE IS
AWARE OF NOT ONLY THE PROMISE OF
THE FISCAL SYSTEM THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY DEVELOPING BUT ALSO.
THE PROBLEMS AND DELAYS THAT
HAVE RECENTLY PLAGUED THAT PRO
THE AUDITOR CAME BACK WITH A
QUITE A FEW DIFFERENT
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ALSO SOME
VERY ALARMING STATISTICS ON HIS
CAL.
AND PARTICULARLY THE AUDITOR WAS
CONCERNED AT THAT THE SLOW
PROGRESS IN DEPLOYING PHYS CAL
WAS GOING TO BECAUSE THE
DIFFERENT STATE DEPARTMENTS TO
NOT BE ABLE TO RELIABLY REPORT.
THEIR REVENUE AND EXPENDITURE
FIGURES AND THAT THAT MIGHT
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE STATE'S
CREDIT RATING.
UNFORTUNATELY THE THAT TURNED
OUT TO BE OPPRESSION OBSERVATION
BECAUSE JUST LAST MONTH STATE
COMPTROLLER BETTY SENT A LETTER
TO THE LEGISLATURE WHICH I'M
SURE YOU'VE ALL READ.
THAT -- EXPRESSED THAT EXACT
SAME CONCERN AND IN A MUCH MORE
NEAR TERM WAY IN FACT AS SHE IT
IN PREPARING TO ISSUE THE
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORT THE SO CALLED CFR.
SHE IS CONCERNED THAT PERHAPS
THE STATE AUDITOR'S WILL RETURN
A WERE A KID A QUALIFIED --
AUDIT OF FINDING INSTEAD OF
INSTEAD OF A SUPPORTIVE FINDING
AND THAT THAT MIGHT CAUSE OUR
CREDIT RATING TO DECLINE SO THIS
BILL MERELY IMPLEMENTS SOME OF
THE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR
THAT WOULD THEY WOULD IMPOSE.
SOME REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ON
HIS CAL SO THAT WE GET OUR ARMS
AROUND THE ARE LEGISLATIVE ROLE
IN -- OVERSEEING THE DEPLOYMENT
OF THE FISCAL SYSTEM SO -- WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DRIVE A THANK YOU -- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
AND AGAIN WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS MEASURE BUT WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THERE ARE MINOR
AND ABSORB OF THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH IT AS MUCH OF
THIS INFORMATION IS CURRENTLY
REPORTED.
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE COMMITTEE --
SINKS IN NINE ANY.
ANYBODY A PAPER FROM THE PUBLIC.
THE COMMON IN FAVOR OF AB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO A. B..
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN OKAY.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR TACKLING
THIS ISSUE TO SEE IF THIS FITS
COLLEGES AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON FOR OVER A DECADE SO PROCEEDS
AND SPOKE IT'S CLOSE AND IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT.
TO MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
FISCAL ACCOUNTABILITY WE NEED
FOR OUR STATE GOVERNMENTS
APPRECIATE AGAINST.
YOU -- BRING IN THIS PROPOSAL
FOR WHICH I CLOSE I'LL TAKE THAT
AS MY CLOTHES MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU. TO GET A MOTION.
SECOND.
TECHNICAL BUSH'S SECOND MA'AM
SECTOR COULD CALL THE ROLL
PUSHED TING.
TING AYE OBERNOLTE BY REALTY I
BLOOM.
BLOOM HI BRO.
BROUGH AYE CHIU COOPER.
COOPER AYE FONG FONG AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I JONES SAWYER LACKEY.
LACKEY HI Là MON MATHIS.
MATHIS HI MCCARTY MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN
DESPITE MULLIN MURATSUCHI.
RECERTIFY NAZARIAN O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON HIGH RAMOS RAMOS HI
RES REVERSE.
I RUBIO.
STONE STONE AYE WEBER.
WEBER I WICKS WICKS I WOULD.
TING HI TING OBERNOLTE.
REALTY I BLOOM.
BLOOM MY BRO -- I CHIU COOPER.
COOPER AYE FONG FONG AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY HI Là MON MATHIS.
MATHIS BY MCCARTY MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN
DESPITE MULLIN MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE NAZARIAN
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON I RAMOS.
PROMISED BY RADIUS REVERSE.
REVERSE AYE RUBIO.
STONE STONE AYE WEBER.
WEBER HIGH WICKS. SIX FIVE WOULD.
WHAT AYE AYES TWENTY THREE NO
ZERO THANK YOU SO BEFORE WE GO
TO MISS RUBIO'S -- A. B. --
SORRY MISS REVIEWS AB SEVENTEEN
FOURTEEN WE'RE GONNA HAVE MISS
SHELTON FROM DEPARTMENT FINANCE
PRESENT ON MISSION BASED
BUDGETING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M I'M
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY IN FRONT
OF THE FULL COMMITTEE WITH
TYPICALLY PROVIDED UPDATES
REGULAR UPDATES SINCE WE STARTED
THIS UNIT IN. TWENTY SIXTEEN TO
ASSEMBLY SUBCOMMITTEE SIX AND
AND SO SINCE THAT TIME WE'VE
BEEN FAIRLY BUSY ALTHOUGH WE
HAVE A VERY SMALL TEAM A LITTLE
LESS THAN FIVE STAFF DEDICATED
TO THIS IMPORTANT WORK FINANCE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT YOU WERE
PROVIDED SOME DOCUMENTS THAT
PROVIDED -- BROAD SUMMARY OR AN
OVERVIEW OF WHAT WHAT WORK THIS
UNIT DOES TODAY -- AND WHAT
WE'VE COMPLETED SINCE OUR LAST
UPDATE INCLUDING AN OVERVIEW OF
THE REPORT AFTER APPROACH THE
UNIT ORG CHART.
AND A LIST OF OUR CURRENT
PROJECTS THAT ARE UNDER WAY AS
WELL AS AS ONE PAGE SUMMARY OF
OUR FINDINGS ON THOSE REPORTS --
SINCE WE'VE HAD SINCE WE WERE
CREATED WE HAVE COMPLETED THREE
REVIEWS AND THESE ARE FAIRLY
LABOR INTENSIVE AND WE HAVE
CURRENTLY FIVE REVIEWS UNDER
PRODUCT -- IN PROGRESS.
AND THE APPROACH THAT WE'VE
TAKEN HERE IS KIND OF UNIQUE AND
IT REALLY APPLIES AN ALTERNATIVE
BUDGETING METHODOLOGY TO THE
INCREMENTAL BUDGET PROCESS THAT
WE CURRENTLY TAKE -- TO BUILD
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR BUDGET --
BY REALLY WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR
DEPARTMENT PARTNERS -- IN TRYING
TO IDENTIFY THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT DRIVE THE MISSION OF THAT
ORGANIZATION BOTH A VERY CLEARLY
DEFINED STATUTORY MISSION AS
WELL AS THE EXPECTATIONS OF
LET'S SAY SERVICE LEVELS THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED BY THOSE
DEPARTMENTS AND TO CALIFORNIANS --
AS WELL AS TAKING INTO ACCOUNT
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS THAT MIGHT BE
AFFECTED.
AND WE PRIORITIZE AS BEST WE CAN
THE LIMITED RESOURCES OF THE
STATE AND REALLY TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING A BIG
RETURN ON THOSE INVESTMENTS AND
THAT THEIR TARGETED AND
STRATEGIC.
AND WE HAVE HAD A VARIETY OF
FINDING SINCE SINCE WE CREATED
THE UNIT -- IT CAN BE AN
REDUCTION AND RESOURCES THAT CAN
THE ADDITION OF RESOURCES -- AND
I THINK COMING OUT OF RECESSION
AND WE HAVE SEEN NOT TO BE MOST
OFTEN THE CASE -- WHICH WHICH
PRESUMES THAT THERE'S HIGHER
SERVICE LEVEL NEEDS IN THOSE
PARTICULAR ADAM PROPOSALS ARE
PACKAGES THAT MIGHT HAVE COME
BEFORE YOU.
WE ALSO THINK ABOUT IS THERE
UNDERLYING MISSION CHANGED OR
HAS IT BEEN MODIFIED SO WE WILL
COME FORWARD WITH PROPOSALS THAT
CHANGE THAT MISSION THROUGH
BUDGET TRAILER BILL TYPICALLY --
BUT COULD ALSO TAKE A POLICY
PASSED DEPENDING ON HOW IT
AFFECTS THE RESOURCES OF THAT
DEPARTMENT.
AND WE TRY TO LOOK AT
OPPORTUNITIES ARE PLACES WHERE
WE CAN STREAMLINE FUNCTION
FUNCTIONS ARE CONSOLIDATE
FUNCTIONS AND THEN WE REALLY
LOOK AT REGIONAL APPROACHES TO
SERVICE DELIVERIES -- I THINK
PROBABLY THE BEST HIGHLIGHTED
ONE IS WITHIN OUR STATE HOSPITAL
PROGRAM WHICH HAS FIVE DISTINCT
HOSPITALS TO PROVIDE A WIDER.
RANGE OF SERVICES WE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING OUT WAYS TO STANDARDIZE
AND STREAMLINE THE SERVICES THAT
ARE PROVIDED SO THAT EACH
HOSPITAL DOESN'T TAKE THEIR OWN
APPROACH TO THE CARE OF THOSE
BETTER AND COMMITTED THERE.
AND WE WE DO VIEW THIS AS A VERY
IMPORTANT COOPERATIVE WORK
EFFORT THAT WE UNDERTAKE WITH
OUR DEPARTMENTS WITH OUR AGENCY
PARTNERS AND TRY -- TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE WHERE THE
PRIORITIES LIE AND WHERE OUR
PAIN POINTS ARE AND IN TERMS OF
LONG STANDING PROBLEMS OR ISSUES.
I'M ONE THING THAT WE'VE NOTICED
AS THIS PROCESS IT DONE RIGHT IS
VERY LABOR INTENSIVE AND I THINK
AS WE'VE TALKED BEFORE WE DON'T
WANT TO SACRIFICE QUALITY FOR
SPEED AND SO WE'VE TAKEN NOT
VERY MUCH TO HEART -- BUT WE'VE
ALSO LOOKED FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO
TRY.
TO BRING THE CULTURE THE IDEA OF
MISSION BASED REVIEWS INTO OUR
BROADER BUDGET DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS AND SO STARTING LAST
YEAR WE FORMALISE THE PROCESS
THAT WE KIND OF CALL EARLY
ENGAGEMENT.
IN WHICH WE WORK TO IDENTIFY A
FEW HIGH PRIORITY ISSUES IN
SPECIFIC POLICY OR PROGRAM AREAS --
IN ADVANCE OF OUR TYPICAL
TYPICAL BUDGET KICK OFF PROCESS
AND THEN WE DO SOME VERY FOCUSED
TARGETED MEETINGS WITH THOSE
DEPARTMENTS -- AND AGENCIES TO
TRY TO ADDRESS SOME LONG
STANDING PROBLEMS AND TWO
EXAMPLES OF FAT THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN OUR JANUARY TEN
BUDGET -- BOTH THIS YEAR AND
ALSO HAD A A PROPOSAL LAST YEAR --
FOCUSED ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND THEN
ANOTHER PROPOSAL FOCUSED ON AND
THE AT ALPHABET AT ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL.
PROGRAM AND I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
A TOPIC UP LATER IN THE AGENDA.
RELATED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES SO I WILL
PROBABLY WAIT TO TALK ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL INTO THAT
AND TOPIC IS UP IN THE AGENDA.
I'M JUST FOR CONTEXT OR AN IDEA
FOR ABC THOUGH THE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL DEPARTMENT.
WE HAD ORIGINALLY IDENTIFIED IT
AS A MISSION BASED REVIEW WE HAD
COME TO THIS COMMITTEE -- TO TO
UNDERTAKE THAT WE INTENDED TO
START IT AND KICKED IT OFF IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AFTER SEVERAL MEETINGS IT BECAME
CLEAR THAT THEY HAD A MUCH MORE
IMMEDIATE NEED RELATIVE -- TO
THEIR FUNDING STRUCTURE AND KIND
OF A STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE
BETWEEN THE REVENUES AND
EXPENDITURES AND THAT'S WHERE WE
IDENTIFIED IT AND IN A PIVOTED.
TO AN EARLY ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
AND ONE THING I LIKE ABOUT THE
EFFORTS THAT WE DO IS THAT WE DO
VIEW IT AS NIMBLE AND TRYING TO
BE RELEVANT WHEN TOPICS OR
ISSUES COME UP.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY NEED TO MEET
SOME OF THE BUDGET DEADLINES
THAT -- EXCESS SO WITH ABC WE
PUT FORWARD A PACKAGE WAS PART
OF THE APRIL ONE SPRING RELEASE
AND WE HAD HOPED TO COMPLETE IT
SOONER BUT IT TOOK A LITTLE
LONGER AGAIN -- FOCUSING ON
QUALITY NOT DOING IT AND TOO
FAST.
AND THAT PROPOSAL THAT'S BEING
CONSIDERED BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE WILL INCREASE THEIR
LICENSING AND ENFORCEMENT
CAPACITY.
IT KIND OF TRANSFERS AND
CENTRALIZES THERE'S THAT
LICENSING FUNCTIONS INTO A
SINGLE DIVISION WITHIN THE TO
THE DEPARTMENT SO I VIEW THAT AS
REALLY STREAMLINING THAT SO THAT
THEY CAN -- KIND OF BY FOR KATE
THE WORK THAT THEY DO IN THE
FIELD.
IT REESTABLISHES THEIR ABILITY
TO PROMULGATE REGULATIONS AND
ADDRESS A SUBSTANTIAL BACKLOG OF
REGULATORY ISSUES SO LOOKING AT
THAT ORGANIZATION THERE HAD BEEN
A LOT OF STATUS QUO FOR MANY
YEARS AND SO WE REALLY NEED TO
KIND OF RE LOOK AT WHAT DRIVES
THEIR OVERSIGHT AND DIDN'T THEY
ARE ALSO.
LOOKING AT WAYS TO MODERNIZE
THEIR ONLINE -- PROCESSING OF
LICENSING APPLICATIONS AND BEING
ABLE TO RECEIVE FINDS.
YEAH AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INTERNAL AYE AUTOMATION THEY
HAVE STAYED LARGELY A PAPER
BASED DEPARTMENT -- AND AND THEN
AS I SAID BECAUSE OF THE
OPERATING SHORTFALL THEY HAVE A
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD INCREASE
THEIR FEES -- IN MANY AREAS
[inaudible]
AND LET'S SEE -- I DO HAVE I CAN
PROVIDE IF YOU'D LIKE A BRIEF
UPDATE ON EACH OF THE OTHER
PROPOSALS THAT ARE BEFORE YOU
THAT ARE REALLY DIRECT RESULT OF
MISSION BASED REVIEW.
IF THAT'S HELPFUL EXISTE ONE WE
GO TO QUESTIONS MAYBE THAT'LL BE
COVERED AS WE GO TO QUESTIONS.
QUICK QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
COMMENTS [inaudible]
MR GALLAGHER [inaudible]
SO -- I GUESS THIS PROPOSAL JUST
SEEMS A LITTLE BIT OUT OF THE
ORDINARY -- WE'RE DOING THE NO.
I THINK I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
SUPPORTER OF PERFORMANCE BASED
BUDGETING I THINK A LOT OF US
ARE -- BUT WHERE WE KIND OF
GOING OUT OF THAT PROCESS AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN WE HAVE.
THE BILL HERE FOR ONE DEPARTMENT
WHICH IS A HELLO IT'S NOT DALY
LARGE HELLO SORRY GO SO YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ON THAT ONE YEAH
WE'RE WE'RE SORRY WE'RE NOT ON
THIS RUBIO WAS BUILT IN THE
SHELTER IS JUST GIVING A UPDATE
COMMISSION BASE BY THE OKAY.
OKAY REDDIT BUT YOU COULD YOU
COULD ADDRESS MAYBE YOU COULD
SPEAK TO THAT I MEAN YOU KNOW
LIKE OBVIOUSLY THAT'S BEEN IT
SEEMS LIKE THAT MISSION THE
MISSION BASED BUDGETING THIS
PROCESS IS BEING GOING PRETTY
WELL -- AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
BILL THAT'S GOING TO SORT
PROPOSED TO TAKE ONE DEPARTMENT
OUT OF THAT -- AND KINDA SINGLE
THAT OUT -- DO YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS.
ON WHETHER OR NOT WE SHOULD BE
DOING.
SURE SO MISSION BASED BUDGETING
IS.
ALSO VERY LABOR INTENSIVE I MEAN
I AM PERFORMANCE BASED BUDGETING
IS ALSO VERY LABOR INTENSIVE IT
IS SOMETHING WE HAVE TRIED IN
THE PAST -- IT'S BEEN SOME TIME
SO BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO
AND NINETY THREE I WAS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WHEN WE ON WOUND
ABOUT PROCESS SO WE DIDN'T FOR
DEPARTMENTS AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS GENERAL SERVICES AND ONE
OF OUR DATA CENTERS.
WHICH IS -- KIND OF A COMBINED
THING TODAY -- WE CANCELED THAT
PROJECT AFTER THREE YEARS
BECAUSE OVERALL WE VIEWED IT AS
UNSUCCESSFUL IT'S REALLY HARD TO
KIND OF IDENTIFY METRICS TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT THE FUNDING
LEVEL FOR PARTICULAR DEPARTMENT --
WHEN I THINK ABOUT A PROGRAM
LIKE MEDICAID ALL AND ITS
ENTITLEMENT NATURE I THINK IT
BECOMES EVEN MORE CHALLENGING --
BUT AS THEY TALKED ABOUT THIS
EARLY ENGAGEMENT EFFORT WE HAVE
DONE A COUPLE THINGS OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS RELATIVE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES BECAUSE WE NOTED THAT
THERE WAS SOME FISCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT NEEDED TO BE
SHORED UP WITHIN THAT DEPARTMENT
AND SO WE HAVE ADDED -- IN OUR
SCHEDULE AND TRY TO BRING THAT
BRING THEM EARLIER I'M IN A
COUPLE AREAS BOTH IN MENTAL
HEALTH AND IN THEIR FISCAL
OVERSIGHT.
AND DEVELOPMENT OF THE ESTIMATE.
I WOULD JUST CAN ALSO AND WHEN
THIS RUBIO PRESENTED THE BILL
AND STOP -- SIX SHE EXPRESSED A
WILLINGNESS TO REALLY WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AS WITH
DEPARTMENT TO FIGURE OUT HOW --
TO GET BOTH GOALS ACCOMPLISHED
SO I KNOW THAT SHE CHOSE.
THE PERFORMANCE BASED BUDGETING
LABEL BUT I THINK SHE EXPRESSED
A DEFINITE INTEREST IN REALLY
WORKING TOGETHER SO I KNOW THAT --
YOU KNOW WE'RE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL TO MOVE IT FORWARD -- THE
INTENTION I BELIEVE FOR THE
AUTHOR WAS THAT SHE WAS GOING TO
WORK WITH BERMAN OF FINANCE AND
THE COMMITTEE. TO TO KIND OF
WORK TOGETHER -- ANY PARTICULAR
AT THAT PARTICULAR -- DEPARTMENT.
CAME OUT ON THE FUN THAT THAT
BILL CAME OUT OF SOME
FRUSTRATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
IN SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONCE IF
YOU IF YOU WERE ON SUB.
ONE YOU'RE YOU'RE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF SOME OF
THE ISSUES THEY ARE SO I THINK
THAT'S WHY THERE WAS -- MISTER
MATHIS IS SHAKING SENT.
IN AN AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S REALLY
WHY WE WERE -- ENCOURAGING MISS
RUBIO TO MOVE THE BILL FOR BUT
THE SAME TIME TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO WORK BUT APARTMENT
A FINANCE SO THAT WE COULD.
HAVE IT HAS ONE ON ONE PROGRAM
RATHER THAN TWO I THINK YOU
BRING UP AN EXCELLENT POINT
[inaudible]
MISTER FUNK.
FROM FROM A FROM A DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONAL LEVEL CAN YOU CAN
YOU SHED SOME LIGHT AND
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MISSION BASE
REVIEW AND PERFORM PERFORMANCE
SPACE REVIEW.
I MEAN YOU SAID IS VERY.
INTENSIVE LABOR WISE SOUTHWEST.
SO FIRST FIRST I WILL SAY THAT --
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTANTLY AN
INNOVATOR AND LEADER WE REALLY
LOOK KIND OF COINED THIS PHRASE
MISSION BASE REVIEW BECAUSE WE
FELT IT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
FOCUS ON UNDERLYING STATUTE.
OF A PARTICULAR ORGANIZATION AND
REALLY EXAMINE OUR FOR IT ARE
THEY DOING WHAT THEY SHOULD BE
DOING TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS.
AND AND REALLY TRYING TO GET --
KIND OF INSIGHT INTO THAT
PROCESS THROUGH A CLOSE AND
CAREFUL EXAMINATION OF THE
UNDERLYING STATUTORY FRAMEWORK
THE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND THEN WHAT KIND
OF SERVICE LEVEL DO WE WANT TO
HAVE -- RELATIVE TO STAFFING AND
RESOURCING OUR DEPARTMENTS
PARTICULARLY WHEN RESOURCES GET --
MORE LIMITED AND TIGHT
PERFORMANCE BASED BUDGETING IS
REALLY SOMETHING THAT KIND OF
SETS A PARTICULAR GOAL OR TARGET
FOREIGN ORGANIZATION AND THEN
DEPENDING ON HOW THEY'RE DOING
AND MEETING THAT BENCHMARK OR
THAT TARGET.
THEY WOULD COME IN AND THEN
INCREASE RESOURCES OR
POTENTIALLY DECREASE SO IF THE
DEPARTMENT WASN'T PERFORMING
WELL AND IT WAS -- THAT THERE
WAS SOME THOUGHT -- TO NO BETTER
SHORING UP HOW THEY PERFORM YOU
MIGHT GIVE THEM MORE RESOURCES
BUT YOU MIGHT ALSO USE IT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PENALIZE THEM FOR
NOT PERFORMING IN A PARTICULAR
FASHION -- SO THERE THERE'S A
REAL DISTINCTION IT'S DIFFICULT
TO DO I THINK MOST STATES -- DO.
IN USE PERFORMANCE METRICS TO
INFLUENCE OR INFORM BUDGET
CONVERSATIONS I THINK THAT'S
REALLY WHAT CALIFORNIA DOES WHEN
WE THINK ABOUT THAT FROM AN
APPROACH AND METHODOLOGY.
BUT WE DON'T LET THOSE METRICS
DRIVE BUDGET DECISIONS -- AND ON
A MORE OF AN AUTO PILOT TYPE
MODE.
ENGINE JUST AS A FOLLOW UP.
IS.
IS A PERFORMANCE METRIC
CONSIDERED AS PART OF A MISSION
BASED REVIEW -- I I GUESS I'M
I'M SEEING A DISTINCTION.
WITHOUT A DIFFERENCE BUT IN
TERMS OF FROM A FROM A BUDGETARY
SAMPLING.
WOULDN'T YOU WANT TO INCORPORATE
WHETHER THEY'RE ACHIEVING WHAT.
THE GOAL OF LOCAL THE
LEGISLATURE IS OR WHAT THE GOAL
OF THE OF ANY PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS IN TERMS OF
WHETHER THEY ARE.
DESERVING OR NOT DESERVING OF A
BUNCH OF RESOURCES.
I'M CERTAINLY THAT'S A COMPONENT
SO TYPICALLY THE WAY THAT THAT
SHOWS UP IN OUR BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS AS WE MAY
WANT TO INCREASE SAY A LEVEL OF
SERVICE OR ELIMINATE A BACKLOG.
IN SOME WORK SO WE PROVIDE
RESOURCES WE MAY SET UP
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WHETHER
THAT BE TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE TO FINANCE OR
ANOTHER TYPE OF OVERSIGHT INTO
T..
AND WE WOULD PROVIDE REGULAR
UPDATES IN NOT SO WE DO DO A LOT
A WHAT I WOULD CALL A DATA
DRIVEN DECISION -- BUT SOMETIMES
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT PERFORMANCE
IT MIGHT BE OKAY FOR PROCESSING
TO TAKE SIXTY DAYS RATHER THAN
THIRTY DAYS AND THEN YOU COULD
FIND AT A DIFFERENT LEVEL IF YOU
MADE SOME OF THOSE TRADE OFFS
AND IN THE MISSION BASED REVIEW
PROCESS WE VIEW.
THAT AS AN AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK ABOUT THOSE PARTICULAR
TRADE OFFS -- AND TO BE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE MIGHT EITHER
INVEST RESOURCES OR IN IN THE
EXAMPLE THAT ARE PROVIDED FOR A.
B. C. WE KIND OF PULLED A
PROCESS OUT.
FROM AN EXISTING PROCESS AND TRY
TO SET IT UP ON ITS OWN SO COULD
BE BETTER MINE MONITORED AND
TRACK -- IN TERMS OF LICENSING
AND BEING ABLE -- TO ISSUE THOSE
IN A SPECIFIC PERIOD OF TIME.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THE ONE THING I WOULD JUST
REALLY APPRECIATE PER FINANCE
FOR FOR LEADING ON THIS ISSUE I
KNOW.
IF YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
DEPARTMENTS THEY ARE ON THE
SMALLER SIDE COULD PURPOSELY --
WANTING.
TO GET THIS PROCESS GOING WITH
SOME OF THE SMALLER DEPARTMENTS
IN HOPES THAT WE WE WORK UP TO
SOME OF THE LARGE PARTNERS.
BUT THEN AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOU AND FRANKLY DEPARTMENTS FOR
STEPPING FORWARD TO NOSE TIME ON
THE DEPARTMENT'S -- SIDE ACROSS
THE TIME ON THE ON THE ON
FINANCE ASIDE TO REALLY
APPRECIATE IT THIS PROCESS SO.
WITH THAT SINGLE.
MR OBERNOLTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO --
MISTER CHANG AND I SEVERAL YEARS
AGO JOINT AUTHORED A BILL THAT.
KIND OF PUT US ON THIS PATH TO
WHAT WHAT WITHIN CALLED ZERO
BASED BUDGETING WHICH ARE.
NOW CALLING MISSION BASED
BUDGETING SO I'M VERY EXCITED
AND HAPPY TO SEE YOU MOVING
FORWARD WITH THAT -- I THINK
THAT.
WHEN WE DID THAT IT WAS BORN OUT
OF FRUSTRATION FOR THE WAY THAT
THE CURRENT BUDGETING PROCESS
WORKED AND A DESIRE TO SEE IT
WORK BETTER IN A WAY THAT
HOLISTICALLY LOOKED AT?
WHAT EACH DEPARTMENT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING AND WHETHER
OR NOT THEY HAD SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO DO IT?
SO WE WERE IN HOPES THAT AS
YOU'RE DOING NOW WE START WITH A
SMALLER DEPARTMENTS
TRANSITIONING OVER TO THE BIGGER
DEPARTMENTS CAN YOU TALK ABOUT.
THE THE YOU TALK ABOUT A COUPLE
OF THE INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENTS
YOU TALK ABOUT LIKE THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT VIEW.
HOW THINGS ARE GOING IN YOUR
OPINION -- WHAT YOU THINK THE
TIME LINE WOULD BE FOR
TRANSITIONING TO LARGER
DEPARTMENTS AND WHETHER OR NOT
YOU THINK THAT MAYBE THIS WOULD
BE ULTIMATELY THE WAY THAT WE DO
BUDGETING INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT?
METHODOLOGY.
SURE -- AND SO FIRST WE DID TRY
TO START WITH SMALLER
DEPARTMENTS BUT WE DID ALSO TAKE
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS WHICH I WOULD SAY IS
NOT A SMALL.
BY ANY STRETCH OF THE
IMAGINATION ONE OF THE LESSONS
THAT WE'VE LEARNED PARTICULARLY
IN NOT REVIEW BECAUSE IT WAS SO
BIG AND WE KIND OF HAD
EVERYTHING ABOUT THEIR
OPERATIONS AND PROGRAMS THAT WE
WERE LOOKING AT IT'S PROBABLY TO
PICK -- WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS THAT PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
SINCE EARLY -- TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ADMITTEDLY WITH MY TEAM AS IT'S
I THINK THERE'S JUST UNDER FIVE
OF US FROM A FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT PERSPECTIVE SO.
JUST -- THE WORK IS TIME
INTENSIVE IT TAKES A LOT OF TIME
AND RESOURCES ON THE
DEPARTMENT'S PERSPECTIVE OVER
TIME AND IN THEIR TIME -- AND
STATE HOSPITALS IN PARTICULAR WE
ARE ABOUT WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER
YOU KNOW MATHEMATICALLY HALFWAY
THROUGH.
AND WE HAVE THREE BIG PROPOSALS
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR
WHICH ART IS KIND OF THE FIRST
BIG PIECES OF WORK TO COME OUT
OF THAT.
AND WE HAVE SMALLER ONES SO VERY
SMALL DEPARTMENT PER -- PERSONAL
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD -- IT
WAS DONE IN A VERY SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
WHAT WE TOOK ON AND I THINK WHAT
YOU'VE CAUTIONED US WHEN WE
FIRST MET WAS VERY AMBITIOUS --
WE ALSO HAVE TO KIND OF FIT OUR
WORK IN ACROSS OUR DEPARTMENT'S
PORTFOLIO BECAUSE WE TRY NOT TO
JUST DO IT IN ISOLATION SO WE
WORK WITH OUR BUDGET.
COUNTERPARTS IN THE RESEARCH AND
ANALYSIS UNIT THAT I AM MANAGING
AND AND WANT TO BRING THEM ALONG
AND BRING THEM UP TO SPEED -- IF
NOT HAVE THEM PARTICIPATE ON
SOME OF THE A VERY INTENSIVE
SITE VISITS WE DO SO FOR
INSTANCE IN STATE HOSPITALS WE
WENT.
TO ALL FIVE HOSPITALS -- SOME OF
THEM MORE THAN ONCE WE WENT AND
VISITED AID -- JAIL BASED
FACILITY THAT DEALING WITH OUR
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
POPULAR SHIN SO WE IT'S A VERY
INTENSE FIELD KIND OF FOCUSED --
REVIEW -- SO MY CONCLUSION IS
THAT I THINK TAKING OFF MORE
BITE SIZE PIECES -- IS PROBABLY
EASIER AND MORE DURABLE AND MORE
ANALOGOUS TO WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO PERMEATE A LITTLE BIT
MORE THROUGH OUR BUDGET PROCESS
WHICH IS THE EARLY ENGAGEMENT SO.
I VIEWED THE MISSION BASED
REVIEWS KIND OF HELPING TO
INFORM THIS EARLY ENGAGEMENT
EFFORT WHICH WERE TRYING TO DO
MORE AND MORE -- IN THE
DEPARTMENT BUT IF YOU REALLY
WANTED TO DO THIS ON EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO FROM A BUDGET
BUILDING PERSPECTIVE -- FIRST
NOT EVERYTHING LENDS ITSELF TO
THAT SUMMER VERY WORKLOAD WITH
JUDY DRIVEN PROPOSALS SO WE
PROBABLY DON'T NEED TO INVEST
THAT KIND OF TIME AND ENERGY ON
WHERE IS OTHERS NEED TO FOCUS
LOOKS AND PARTICULAR PROGRAMS OR
AREAS BUT IF YOU WANTED TO DO IT.
ACROSS THE BOARD IT WOULD IT
WOULD -- SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
THE SIZE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I'M NOT SURE THAT IT
WOULD RESULT IN THE OUTCOMES
THAT YOU'RE KIND OF WOULD BE
LOOKING FOR TO DO THAT SO I
THINK CONTINUE TO DO THE
TARGETED FOCUSED REVIEWS.
PRIORITIZED -- BY EACH OF OUR
PROGRAM BUDGET MANAGER AREAS --
WHICH LARGELY LINE UP WITH OUR
CABINET AREAS AND THE DEPARTMENT.
IS IS PROBABLY A REASONABLE
APPROACH IT'S JUST GOING TO TAKE
TIME TO WORK OUR WAY THROUGH.
THOSE ISSUES AND AND THEN THERE
ARE ALSO OTHER PURCHASE THAT
WORK -- SO FOR INSTANCE THE WORK
OF OF SAY OUR OFFICE OF STATE
AUDITS AND EVALUATION ON
PARTICULAR AREAS -- OF THE STATE
IS IS ALSO ANOTHER APPROACH OR
TOOL THAT WE KIND OF HAVE IN OUR
FINANCE TOOL BELT TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS.
SURE THAT THAT'S PROBABLY THAT'S
WHERE ABOUT WHERE WE THOUGHT WE
WERE GOING TO LAND RIGHT WAS
THAT THIS WASN'T GOING TO BE THE
ANSWER -- FOR DOING EVERY
DEPARTMENT EVERY YEAR BUT
PERHAPS THIS WAS GOING TO INFORM
OUR OTHER BUDGETING PRACTICES SO
ONE OF THE HOPES WHEN WE STARTED
WAS THAT THE TRULY LARGE
DEPARTMENTS LIKE -- DEPARTED
TRANSFER ASIAN FOR EXAMPLE WE
KNEW THAT WE WERE GOING TO BE
ABLE -- TO MISSION BASED BUDGET
THOSE DEPARTMENTS IN ANY GIVEN
YEAR BUT WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
LITTLE BITE SIZED PIECES AND
DOING ON A ROLLING BASIS -- IS
THAT STILL THE PLAN AND YOU HAVE
A A PLAN TO TACKLE THOSE LARGER
PROJECTS SO SO CERTAINLY THAT IS
THE CONCEPT OF THE IDEA FOR A
LARGER DEPARTMENTS -- I DON'T
KNOW THAT IF IT'S GOING TO BE
SOLELY MISSION BASED REVIEWS BUT
A COMBINATION OF OUR MISSION
BASED REVIEWS ON THIS EARLY
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS.
THAT WE STARTED LAST YEAR I
THINK HELP US BREAK THOSE BIGGER
DEPARTMENTS INTO BITE SIZE
CHUNKS -- TRANSPORTATION WE HAVE
BEEN KIND OF WORKING ON THAT
OVER SOME PERIOD OF TIME --
THOUGH I THINK IMPLEMENTATION OF
SB ONE KIND OF SHIFTED THE FOCUS
AND NOT ORGANIZATION AND THEY
CONTINUE TO DO THEIR CAP OUT LEE
SUPPORT PROGRAM THROUGH A ZERO
BASED PROCESS BASED ON THE
REVENUE THAT'S AVAILABLE IN ANY
GIVEN YEAR.
SO I I THINK THAT'S TRUE THAT WE
WILL YOU KNOW TRY TO BE LOOKING
AT THAT AND WE'LL TAKE.
PIECES OF BIG DEPARTMENTS OVER
TIME AND ADDRESS THEM EITHER
THROUGH THE MISSION BASED REVIEW
EARLY ENGAGEMENT WITH HAD A
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGE IN OUR
ADMINISTRATION OBVIOUSLY -- WITH
THE ELECTION AS WELL AS A CHANGE
IN OUR ORGANIZATION AND SO OUR
PLAN IS TO REGROUP IN THE SUMMER.
AND TALK AS A DEPARTMENT WITH
OUR LEADERSHIP AND EXECUTIVES IN
THE DEPARTMENT TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT OUR NEXT SET OF PRIORITIES
ARE AND OUR CURRENT FOCUS IS
REALLY FINISHING WHAT WE STARTED
WE HAVE FIVE REVIEWS STILL UNDER
WAY.
WE'VE BEEN KIND OF BRINGING
RESULTS AS WE CAN ON THOSE
PROPOSALS I THINK THEY'RE
SEVERAL PROPOSALS BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
TO WE WRAP THIS UP SO TAKING ON
NEW STUFF RIGHT NOW I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY NOT IN OUR BEST
INTEREST.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SING THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MISTER COOPER WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING THIS RUBIO AS BILL AB --
SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN GOOD MORNING
THIS CHAIR MEMBERS OBVIOUSLY ON
NOT MISS RUBIO BUT HER PLANE WAS
DELAYED -- SO SHOULD BE HERE
SHORTLY -- BUT MISTER CHAIRMAN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN ON BEHALF
OF THE AUTHOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RUBIO.
DURING SOMEONE HEARINGS CYLINDER
RUBIO AND MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERNS TIME AND
TIME AGAIN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IN THEIR ABILITY TO
DELIVER IN A RESPONSIBLE MANNER.
THE COMMISSION ALSO NOTES DH CS
THE TOTAL BUDGET PROJECTED BE
JUST ABOVE ONE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY INCLUDING ALL
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS.
GIVING D. H. C. S. THE LARGEST
PART WILL BUDGET IN THE STATE.
IN RECENT YEARS THE SIZE AND
COMPLEXITY OF DCS HAS RESULTED
IN SIZEABLE BUDGET ERRORS DUE TO
POOR INTERNAL PROCEDURES. FOR
EXAMPLE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
MEDI CAL ESTIMATE WAS FOUND TO
BE OFF BY ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION THAT'S BILLION WITH A B..
DUE TO MISCALCULATION OF COST IN
AN INCORRECT ACCOUNTING FOR
RETROACTIVE FEDERAL DRUG REBATE
PAYMENTS.
THESE TOURS WERE SO LARGE THAT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
PROPOSED OFFSETTING CUTS TO WHAT
IS THE SPENDING PRIORITIES TO
PAY FOR THE LOSS FUNDING.
IN ADDITION THIS MASSIVE AIR DH
CS HAS CONTINUE MISMANAGED SOME
OF THE SMALLER OPERATIONS.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THIS OCCURRED
THE DEPARTMENT'S HANDLING OF HIS
SUICIDE PREVENTION HOTLINE.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE AND LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE ACS IN ORDER TO
OPERATE THESE HOT LINES.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
APPROPRIATE AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION HOWEVER IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN DURING A
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING WERE
INFORMED THAT DESPITE THE EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION OF FUNDING.
DH CS WAS NOT OPERATING A
SUICIDE PREVENTION HOTLINE AT
ALL.
ON TOP OF THAT THE PURPOSE
ASKING FOR ANOTHER FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
AFTER A LOT OF BACK AND FORTH IN
LETTERS DCS MADE THE ARGUMENT
THAT DID YES REGULATIONS.
PREVENTING THEM FROM FTA
CONTRACT WITH THE VENDOR TO
OPERATE THE HOTLINES RESULTING
IN A TWO YEAR DELAY.
HOWEVER AFTER STAFF CONTACTED
TGS WAS BUT TO OUR ATTENTION
THAT NO SUCH REGULATIONS EXIST
THAT DCS WAS NOT BOUND BY ANY
RULES SET FORTH.
THE PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE OR THE
STRAIGHT STATE ADMINISTRATIVE
MANUAL.
THIS IS EITHER A BLATANT LIE ARE
YET ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
INCOMPETENCE.
THIS IS A DMV WERE ERRORS IN
THIS MANAGER RESULTS IN
INCREASED WAIT TIMES.
THIS IS THE DEPARTMENT WERE
MISMANAGEMENT THESE PEOPLE'S
LIFE AND HEALTH AT STAKE.
THEY NEED TO BE A HIGHER
STANDARD.
FROM THE TOP ON DOWN IS THROUGH
THE DH CS NEED THE CULTURE
CHANGE AN INCREASED FOCUS
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY SERVICES
AND RESULTS TO CALIFORNIANS.
AB SEVENTY FOURTEEN WILL BEGIN A
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION ON HOW TO
BEST IMPROVE JCS INCREASE
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME TO
PRESENT HERE TODAY LOOK FOR
PUTTING THE BILL THIS RUBIO DOES.
AND FOR THE FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OUR FINAL.
HI RANDALL OR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- WE AGREE WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THE NEED -- TO IMPROVE
ESTIMATING -- ON MEDI CAL AT THE
DEPARTMENT -- BUT I THINK WE
HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENCE OF OF APPROACH AND
AND SO CURRENTLY WE ARE RIGHT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL -- WE
HAVE TO PROPOSALS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY BEFORE THE HEALTH
HUMAN SERVICES SUBCOMMITTEE THIS
YEAR TO TRY TO ADDRESS THESE
PROBLEMS -- THE FIRST -- BEING --
SIGNIFICANT PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO DH CS TO
IMPROVE -- FISCAL ESTIMATING AND
STRENGTH AND CASH FLOW
MONITORING -- AND I'M I'M GLAD
THAT THE ARCHIVE THE AUTHOR'S
ARGUMENTS -- DRESSED -- THE THE
SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY RELATING
TO DRUG REBATES -- BECAUSE WE
HAVE A SECOND PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD CREATE A SPECIAL FUND --
THAT WOULD HELP US MANAGE THAT
VOLATILITY -- RESULTING FROM
DRUG REBATES AND HOPEFULLY BRING --
SOME GREATER DEGREE OF CERTAINTY
TO GENERAL FUND SPENDING ON MEDI
CAL OVER TIME -- I'M HAPPY
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT THOSE
PROPOSALS.
DID YOU EVER COMMENT ON THE
PERFORMANCE BASED BUDGETING
ASPECT OF IT.
I I THINK THAT THE CORE PART OF
THAT ARGUMENT IS JUST THAT THE
THE PERFORMANCE BASED BUDGETING
OF MY COLLEAGUE -- MENTIONED THE
THE AMOUNT OF TIME AND RESOURCES
LABOR THAT GOES INTO THAT SORT
OF PROCESS.
AND OUR MAIN CONCERN IS THAT
THAT THE BILL WOULD DISTRACT
FROM THESE OTHER EFFORTS THAT
WERE WERE BUT I PROPOSING THIS
YEAR BEFORE THE COMMITTEE SAYS
IF I GET A RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
GIVE THEM MORE MONEY.
AND THE ISSUE WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
AS I WAS WITH HER PRESENT IT IS
JUST OVER CAL OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME VERY TO
MEDICARE'S AND WE'RE TALKING --
WAS AT ONE POINT. EIGHT BILLION
ONE POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
AND TWENTY BILLION ONE PLATE
GLASS SNIFFING AMOUNT SO.
THAT'S PLAY THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING AND IT'S IT'S LEGISLATURE
THE THREE BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT
TO WITH OVERSIGHT SORE GIVE YOU
MORE MONEY BUT WHERE IS THE
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY.
I GUESS THAT'S THAT'S MY
QUESTION.
I THINK THAT IS SO I THINK WE
AGREE THAT THERE IS THIS GROWING
COMPLEXITY IN THE PROGRAM THAT
THE AMOUNTS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HAVE GROWN OVER TIME --
I'M NOT REALLY SURE EXACTLY HOW
PERFORMANCE BASED BUDGETING IS
AIMED TO ADDRESS THOSE THOSE
TYPES OF PROBLEMS BECAUSE THE
THE THE THE ESTIMATING --
VARIATIONS HAVE REALLY COME FROM --
THE THAT THAT THE DEPARTMENT IS
ON A CASH BASIS -- THE TIMING OF
VERY DIFFICULT TO PREDICT
TRANSACTIONS CAN CAN HAVE A HUGE
EFFECT ON WHAT SPENDING IS FROM
YEAR TO YEAR AND I THINK THAT'S
THE KIND OF THING THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN THE PAST -- AND WHILE I
ACKNOWLEDGE THE THE AUTHOR'S
ARGUMENT ABOUT GIVING THEM MORE
RESOURCES KIND OF AN INCENTIVE --
PROBLEM I SUPPOSE -- THE THE
CHALLENGES HERE REALLY RELATE TO
THE COMPLEXITY OF THESE
TRANSACTIONS AND AND BEING ABLE
TO HAVE THE DEPARTMENT BETTER
COORDINATE.
BETWEEN UNITS AND AND AND
ESSENTIALLY TRACK THESE THESE
TRANSACTIONS BETTER I THINK THAT
WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT THOSE --
THOSE TYPES OF INSTRUMENTS ARE
ARE WHAT'S GOING TO IMPROVE THE
ESTIMATE OVER TIME.
QUESTION FROM THE SHELTON SO ON
DO YOU ANTICIPATE -- THIS
DEPARTMENT BEING ON THE LIST ANY
TIME SOON.
I GUESS THAT THE THE BROADER
QUESTION IS IS.
THE ULTIMATE MISSION OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS TO INCREASE HEALTH
CARE ACCESS FOR FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
AND AT TIMES -- THE COMMITTEE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE HAS FELT THAT
THE DEPARTMENT'S BEEN.
SOMEWHAT COMBATIVE FOR SOMEONE --
THEY HAVE SOMEWHAT OF A
DRACONIAN APPROACH SO THAT IT'S
NOT SO MUCH THAT THEY'RE TRYING
TO INCREASE ACCESS BUT ALMOST.
THERE THERE ARE THINGS THAT
SOMETIMES PENALIZED -- THIS IS A
CALIFORNIA FROM BEING TO ACCESS
HEALTH CARE SO THAT DOES SEEM TO
BE SORT OF A IN CONFLICT WITH
THEIR MISSION.
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THOSE ARE
CERTAINLY IMPORTANT THINGS TO BE
CONSIDERING AND EVALUATING IN
THE PROGRAM THAT SAID THE REVIEW
THAT MY COLLEAGUE SPOKE OF WAS
SOMETHING THAT I INITIATED WHEN
I WAS MANAGING THAT PARTICULAR
AREA -- BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN
WITH THEIR ESTIMATE PROCESS AND
THERE ARE EIGHT UNIT THAT HAVE
TOUCH POINTS IN MOUNT PROCESS
MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR US
TO GET A HANDLE ON AND I THINK
THAT AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
WE HAVE TO GET A HANDLE ON THAT
AND I THINK SHORING UP SOME OF
THESE PROCESS SEES HAVING BETTER
REPORTING ACCOUNTABILITY
PREDICTABILITY MONTHLY
RECONCILIATIONS ALL OF THE
THINGS.
THAT ARE PART OF THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S BEING HAT'S BEFORE YOU
TODAY ARE GOING TO BE IMPORTANT
ELEMENTS TO HELPING NOT
ORGANIZATION AND I THINK THEN
WHEN YOU GET THAT PICTURE.
THAT WILL ACTUALLY HELP BETTER
INFORM SOME OF THOSE PROGRAM
DELIVERY COMPONENTS THAT WOULD
BE CONSIDERED AND CERTAINLY WE
WILL AND TAKE YOUR INTEREST IN
PRIORITY BACK TO OUR PPM GROUP
ARE PROGRAM BUDGET MANAGER GROUP.
AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR
PRIORITIES OVER THE SUMMER WITH
THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE WHICH
TALK ABOUT DELIVERY STANDARDS
AND HERE'S TO SUBVENTIONS A BIG
THING WILL BE TO OUR OUR LGBT.
LGBT Q. YOUTH ARE ARE VETERANS
AT BIG ISSUE A SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND THEY'RE FUNDED
FROM A POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS.
THEY NEVER STAND UP THEIR
SUICIDE HOTLINE NEVER STOOD UP.
MAY HAVE THE GALL TO ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL. FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION MORE ON TOP OF THAT IT
IS SOME POINT.
AND THAT'S THAT'S ACTUAL RELEASE
REAL STUFF THAT'S REAL DEAL
PEOPLE TO KILL THEMSELVES AND
I'M SURE.
IF THIS IS BEEN IN PLACE WE MAY
PREVENTED SOME OF TAKING THEIR
OWN LIFE.
SO IT AT SOME POINT THINGS HAVE
TO CHANGE.
AND THAT THIS IS REAL THIS
PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE TALKING ABOUT
HERE NOT SOME BUDGET NOT SOME
NUMBER PERFORMANCE BASED DANDER
IT'S THEY'VE IT THEY HAVE FALLEN
DOWN THE JOB.
AND FOR US TO Q. FIFTEEN TO FUND
THEM IN.
THE STATUS QUO IS UNACCEPTABLE.
PEOPLE EITHER DEALING WITH.
THANK YOU DOCTOR.
YES -- I I APPRECIATE.
THE PRESENTATION IN THE ISSUE
THAT YOU'RE BRINGING FORTH WHICH
OBVIOUSLY IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
WHAT I THINK WHAT I'M TRIP
WRESTLING WITH AN AYE MAYBE
THOUGH THE START TO IS THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN WHAT YOU'RE
REQUESTING?
AND THE SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM
OF THESE ARE -- THIS IS A MAJOR
ISSUE IN TERMS OF LEADERSHIP.
OVERSIGHT I'M NOT SURE IF IF WE
DOING THAT THE THE BUDGET PIECE
IN TERMS OF PERFORMANCE BUDGET
THAT WILL ACTUALLY GET TO THE
PROBLEM WE HAVE WE OBVIOUSLY
HAVE SOME.
SERIOUS PROBLEMS IN LEADERSHIP
WITH REGARDS TO PEOPLE TAKING A
CHARGE IN MAKING SURE THE
PROGRAM TO IMPLEMENTED AND ALL
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AND I
COULD SEE OUT.
IF WE DO THE BUDGETING I I'M I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
CONNECTION IS BETWEEN THIS
REQUEST AND THAT AND OF AND
PROBABLY CAME OUT OF SHEER
FRUSTRATION.
OF SAYING YOU KNOW WE WANT TO
HOLD ON THE MONEY AND AND MAKE
SURE YOU'RE NOT SPENDING MONEY
THAT THAT THAT SHOULDN'T BE
THERE WHATEVER IT MAY BE.
BUT IT SEEMS THAT THAT'S ONE
THING THAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
PERFORMANCE BASED BUDGETING
PROCESS WHICH IS SOMEWHAT LITTLE
BIT.
QUITE DIFFERENT THAN BASICALLY
TALKING ABOUT OVERSIGHT
MANAGEMENT LEADERSHIP AND
ACCOUNTABILITY I MEAN.
THEY HAVE SOME CONNECTION BUT I
COULD SEE IS ENGAGING IN THIS
PROCESS WITH THE OF THE
BUDGETING PROCESS AND GETTING
THAT PART.
DOWN AND THEN STILL HAVING THIS
OVER HERE BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
FOLKS WHO ARE WHO ARE BASICALLY
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE'VE ASKED TO AND BEING
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THOSE.
THINGS AND COMING BACK AND
REPORTING TO US WHEN THINGS ARE
NOT THERE OR NOT SHOULD BE THERE
SO.
IF YOU KNOW YOU COULD YOU
CONNECT THE DOTS OR BECAUSE EVEN
IF YOU JUST SAY IT WELL WITH
GOD'S WHETHER WE DO THIS THIS
AND THIS WE NEED TO DO THIS
WHICH IS TRUE BUT SO SOME TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT.
WHETHER NOT IF WE IF WE ENGAGE
IN THIS BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE A SYSTEMATIC PROCESS OF
DOING THIS WITH AN AD THAT WOULD
GET US.
TO THE SOLUTION TO THIS
PARTICULAR PROBLEM QUICKLY.
SURE I WAS AT THE EDGE THAT
QUESTION THE AUTHORS NOT HERE
SHE'S ON A PLANE RIGHT NOW -- SO
I'M I'M SITTING TO ME LET ME
TAKE A CRACK AT A SO SO DOCTOR
BY THINKING YOU YOU BROUGHT UP A
POINT THAT MR GALLAGHER BROUGHT
UP THAT THAT'S AN EXCELLENT
POINT.
SO.
WE DO HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE BILL
TODAY TO MOVING ON COMMITTEE.
BUT THE AUTHOR HAS COMMITTED TO
TO WORK WITH US BUT ALSO TO WORK
WITH FINANCE SO WE CAN REALLY
ALIGNED ALONG THIS PROCESS RIGHT
SO I THINK.
THE AUTHOR HAD ORIGINALLY.
CHOSEN TO USE THE PERFORMANCE
BASED BUDGETING A PROPOSAL BUT
WE ALSO THE COMMITTEE LET HER
KNOW ABOUT THIS MISSION MISSION
BASED BUDGETING PROPOSAL THAT'S
READY IN THE WORKS I KNOW IT'S
NOT.
THAT WELL KNOWN THROUGHOUT
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE WE WE
CONSISTENTLY MYSELF MISTRAL
MULTI.
THIS MCCARTY BECAUSE AS WE GET
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS FROM OF
MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUE SO.
I THINK BASED ON THAT
INFORMATION SHE WANTED.
TO STEP MEETING WITH PUBLIC
FINANCE TRY TO WORK OUT A PATH
BEFORE WE ARE WE ARE SUPPORT
ABOUT THE BILL MOVING FORWARD.
TODAY EVEN IN ITS CURRENT FORM
BECAUSE WE DO THINK IT HELPS
CONTINUE THIS DISCUSSION ON A
DEPARTMENT THAT AT TIMES HASN'T
BEEN THE MOST RESPONSIVE TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
I'M THINKING WE HOPE THAT BY
WORKING WITH PUBLIC FINANCE WE
CAN.
FIND A SOLUTION THAT WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON ALL OF US AND AND
REALLY MADE A MOVE THIS AGENCY
FOR IT SO CAN REALLY SERVE.
ITS MISSION ABOUT PROVIDING
GREATER HEALTH CARE ACCESS FOR
ALL OF US MR WORLD.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO --
I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
EFFORT TO INCREASE OUR
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
APARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES I
pLONGER TEN YEAR FOR THE AVERAGE
LEGISLATOR.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT.
WE WILL EXERCISE THAT OVERSIGHT
ROLE MORE OFTEN AND I THINK THIS
IS -- THAT THE THE FAILURES THAT
YOU'VE RAISED -- IS AN EXCELLENT
CATALYST FOR US TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT -- I DO SHARE THE CHAIRS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE MECHANISM BY
WHICH THIS BILL GOES ABOUT THAT
OVERSIGHT YOU HEARD THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TESTIFIED
THAT.
WE TRY PERFORMANCE BASED
BUDGETING WE CONSIDER THAT A
FAILURE WHEN WE TRY TO THREE
YEARS AGO -- I'M NOT SURE WHY IT
WOULD MAKE SENSE TO BRING THAT
BACK ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'VE GOT
TO OTHER FORMS OF BUDGETING THAT
WERE ALREADY WORKING ON IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE AUTHOR IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO AMEND THE BILL TO
PERHAPS -- FITTED INTO THE
CURRENT MISSION BASED BUDGETING
FRAMEWORK AND WITH THAT
COMMITMENT IN PLACE I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT IT
SHOULD THE BILL COME TO THE
FLOOR IN ITS CURRENT FORM -- I
WILL RE EVALUATE THAT SUPPORTED
I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE DO THE
SAME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND.
BUT BEFORE WE GET THAT ANY
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
REMEMBER THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEE NOW WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND MAN SECRETARY COULD CALL
THE ROLL.
TING.
TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE HI BLOOM.
BLOOM LIBRO. TO CHIU AYE COOPER.
COOPER HI FONG.
FONG AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GARCIA.
SEE I JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER
HIGH LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LIMóN.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS.
MCCARTY AYE AYE MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ.
WELL I JUST FIVE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE MURATSUCHI.
AYE NAZARIAN.
HI O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE RAMOS.
REYES.
REVERSE.
REVERSED HI RUBIO.
STONE STONE AYE WEBER.
WEBER I WICKS.
WICKS FIVE WHAT.
WHAT BY ICE TWENTY FOUR NO ZERO
THANK YOU COULD YOU -- GO BACK
THROUGH AND COLLAPSE MEMBERS
PLEASE.
AND WE CAN START WITH THE CA A
LEVEL.
YOU SEE.
ELEVEN TO ON AB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN TWO HI Là
MON.
Là MON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
WELL IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE RADIUS RUBIO.
I TWENTY EIGHT ZERO ON A. B..
THREE TWO THREE TWO CHIU AYE
LIMóN.
LIMóN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HI MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE.
NAZARIAN HIGH REYES RUBIO ICE
TWENTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO THANK YOU SO MY APOLOGIES
TO OUR LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S THE
COMMITTEE HAS GONE ON A LITTLE
BIT LONGER THAN WE HAD HOPED WE
HAVE SESSION NOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO COME
UP MAYBE GIVE A QUICK COMMENT
FROM THE MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE.
AND THEN WHAT WE WOULD WANT TO
DO IS PROBABLY INVITE YOU BACK
TO OUR NEXT FULL COMMITTEE
HEARING TO HAVE A MORE ROBUST
DISCUSSION.
MY APOLOGIES -- FOR THIS
COMMITTEE GOING A LITTLE BIT
LONGER THAN ANTICIPATED.
I WANTED TO INTRODUCE THE
COMMITTEE TO OUR NEW LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST MR PANIC IN ASKING JUST
TO COME FORWARD SAY HI IN AGAIN --
INTRODUCED HIMSELF TO THE TO THE
COMMITTEE -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MISTER VICE
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS HI MY NAME
IS KATE PETTITTE CAME THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND I DO
LOOK FORWARD TO INTERACTING WITH
YOU ENGAGING AS WE GO THROUGH
THE CONCLUSION OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS I'VE BEEN BUSY WITH --
STAFF ACROSS THE STREET --
GEARING UP FOR THAT AND WE'VE
BEEN HAVING MEETINGS ABOUT --
COORDINATING OUR RESOURCESFOR
THAT AND THEN THINKING --
FURTHER AHEAD -- MISTER KING YOU
MENTIONED THE WILDFIRES IN THE
KIND OF TAKING A LONG TERM
PERSPECTIVE AND SO THAT IS -- I
WAS YOU KNOW.
IT WAS RIGHT IN SYNC WITH SOME
OF THE DISCUSSIONS WE'VE BEEN
HAVING.
ABOUT -- HOPEFULLY PUTTING SOME
OF THE THE KEY POLICY ISSUES
FACING CALIFORNIA ON A RESEARCH
AGENDA.
AFTER THE IN THE PERIOD AFTER
THE BUDGET
IS ENACTED SO.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON ON THOSE ISSUES.
GREAT THANK THANK YOU -- I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY.
QUESTIONS -- COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
DISTRIBUTOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK I
SPEAK FOR THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE
WHEN -- I TELL YOU HOW EXCITED
WE ARE TO BE WORKING WITH YOU
AND HOW MUCH WE WANT TO ENABLE
YOUR SUCCESS IN THE DEPARTMENT
WE THINK THE LA -- COULD SERVE A
MUCH LARGER ROLE IN ADVISING THE
LEGISLATURE NOT JUST ON
LEGISLATIVE ISSUES BUT I'M BIG
PICTURE ISSUES THE WAY IT HAS
BEEN IN THE PAST AND SO I'M I'M
REALLY GLAD THAT WERE IN SYNC ON
THAT.
AND GLAD TO SEE YOU STARTING
THAT PROCESS OF THINKING BIG SO
WELCOME AND LET US KNOW HOW WE
CAN HELP YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU THE ONLY THING I WOULD
JUST ADD AS THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF FEELING FROM ALL THE
DIFFERENT LEGISLATURE THINK
WANTING TO REALLY.
ENGAGE THE LA -- MORE THERE'S A
LOT OF INTEREST YOU HEARD MR
FRAZIER TALK ABOUT THE VALUE OF
THE REPORTS.
ON THE VALUE OF THE INFORMATION
AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
INTEREST IN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT --
HOW TO HOW TO GAUGE THE ONLY A
MORE WHAT ISSUES THE LA -- WELL
WOULD BE INTERESTED WORKING ON
AND HOW.
MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT WE ARE
TACKLING THAT ARE MUCH SUS MUCH
MORE SYSTEMIC ISSUES -- THAT
REALLY NEED A COMPLEX -- LOOK
REALLY -- REALLY ASKING YOUR
DEPARTMENT TO TO BE PART OF THAT
PROCESS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE I THINK EVERYONE'S
TRYING TO GET TO SESSION SO.
AGAIN MY APOLOGIES THI TIME
WE'RE GONNA BROUGH WE WE KNOW
WHAT BRING YOU BACK NEXT TIME --
FOR THE DISCUSSION ON THE BUDGET
ITSELF BUT PERHAPS AT THAT POINT.
YOU KNOW I THINK WILL BE NICE
MAYBE YOU COULD TALK ABOUT YOU
KNOW HOW YOUR FIRST FEW MONTHS
HAS BEEN SOME OF THE
OBSERVATIONS AND ALSO IN
PARTICULAR.
WHAT WE CAN DO TO SUPPORT YOUR
EFFORTS BUT ALSO -- WHAT THE
BEST WAY TO KEEP OPEN LINES OF
COMMUNICATION AND HOW TO HOW TO
KEEP THAT DIALOGUE BETWEEN OUR
OFFICE IN YOUR OFFICE?
YES GREAT THAT SOUNDS GREAT
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE.
AND WITHOUT THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
IS A JERK